[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> What's going on everybody? I got my
friends with me. I got Chris of Dilemma
Corner, the Islamic Diminator and Giant
DLC. What's going on, guys?
>> What's up, man?
>> Doing good.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Doing good. Well, I got a
doozy for us, man. I got a doozy for us.
We got Shake Um, Iben Fibben Farooq. And
you guys remember I had some runins with
him. I had some discussions with him and
they didn't go his favor. They didn't go
so well for him.
>> Find me an English translation looking
at the meanings from all theat that gave
a different meaning.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait. All right,
beautiful. So, first of all, you just
you literally just tried to throw the
Arabic under the bus. And now he's
appealing to the English and say, "Show
me an English translation that shows a
difference." Who is it that's being
surprised? Is it Muhammad or is it Allah
who's being surprised? He says, "You
wondered why they mocked." And the other
one, Allah says, I wondered why they
mocked. Which one is it?
>> Every English translation around the
world that looked at all the translation
said
>> English. Now he's referring to English,
not the Arabic.
>> Forget the Arabic. Let's go to English.
And so now where we're at, just like he
faked the Hadith when he spoke to me,
>> I asked you, is there anywhere in the
Quran or the Hadith?
>> Yes.
>> Where anybody else other than Jesus is
called the Messiah?
>> Yes.
>> You said yes.
It is a modern comment by a modern
editor. It is not a hadith.
>> He is now faking discussions that we've
had and he's and he's made an AI debate
between me and him. And obviously I I
look like I'm about to convert to Islam
unfortunately with this video.
>> Hold on. Like so let me see if I
understand this. He must have challenged
you to an actual debate. You refused.
Back down. And this forced him. This
left him no alternative since you
refused to debate. This left him no
alternative but to do an AI debate.
something like that.
>> No. Um, no. He never reached out to me
to have a discussion. He's actually gone
radio silent since the last time I spoke
to him about Allah being a father in any
sense. And then all of a sudden, we get
months later this popup video of him
fabricating a AI debate with me.
>> Does he say your name? Is is it clear to
you?
>> It it says God Logic versus Shikman.
That's what it says.
>> So, hang on, hang on, hang on. After
faking a hate crime against himself, now
he's faking debates.
>> Now he's faking debates. He's speaking
hadith, hate crimes. Now debates.
>> Now debates.
>> Hey, hang on. Is anyone here not willing
to debate Shake Usman?
>> A relish opportunity. He ran for me when
I met him in the UK.
>> I I would love to have a conversation
with Usman, man. He's we from the same
side of the town. He's in he's from
California. So,
>> could could Could Could Could Could
Could Could Could Could Could Could he
even like just I mean, assuming he's
traveling and he's so busy. Could he
even just like call in your show?
>> He can call in anytime.
>> Wait, wait, wait. So, he would rather f
I'm trying to I'm trying to process
this, right? Cuz this is a guy that
Muslims regard as like this champion
debater who who who will not actually do
a formal debate.
>> Nope. He won't do a formal debate. He
won't even set up like a a moderated
discussion where you can have just an
open dialogue and maybe somebody neutral
moderates. He he won't even do that with
us. Matter of fact, David, this is the
same guy who showed up in New York a
week or two weeks after us and said,
"Where we at?"
You mean where we announced it like two
months ahead of time that we were going
to be there and so every DA guy on the
planet who wanted to step up to the mic
could have done so but they didn't. They
all ran.
>> Well, let's look into this debate and
let's see how I did. Guys, you ready?
>> Let's see it.
>> All right, let's see how I did. Here we
go.
>> Hey, at least he made you look cool.
>> Hey, see. Hey, so DLC, when you was
asking what what's my like, you know, my
goal a little bit like this. A little
leaner like this. Why do you make
>> Is this inspiration for you? Were you
like I need to end up like this guy?
>> It's a bit disturbing that another man
would make you look like that.
>> It is a little bit, especially a guy,
right? Why would you be like, "Hey, AI,
can you draw me a cartoon image of this
guy, but make him look really buff?"
>> Hey, hey, we need a we need a warning
for all you Muslim ladies who are
watching. Lower your gaze.
>> Lower your gaze.
>> Wait, so is like man going to be like
even more like
And is he going to have is he actually
going to have eyeballs?
>> He's trying not to break the sunna.
>> Oh, good, good, good, good.
>> What's wrong? What's wrong?
>> All right, here we go, guys.
>> Making images, man.
>> If the Quran is preserved, why did Usman
burn copies of the Quran?
>> He burned copies with tribal dialectur.
>> Burning them sounds suspicious.
>> He burned personal copies and dialectal
variations to prevent confusion. The
original Quran was not burned.
>> Do you even have original manuscripts to
prove it? Yes, we still have it in a
museum in Turkey and thousands of
Muslims have memorized every single
word. That's true preservation.
>> So you see how it says look versus
Shikman and this is how he really wishes
it went.
>> I think his mission was how many lies
can I fit into what is this 30 seconds?
How many lies can I fit into 30 seconds?
>> He didn't make himself as buff as you.
So he's like a fantasy. Now, now let's
really quick before we get into the
rebuttals here and start dissecting his
his his argument, let's see what the
what the Muslims say. Let's see. Please
don't bring AI garbage. Just keep
everything original. Don't do this AI.
Stop. Please shake.
>> Oh, nah. We don't need this.
>> Wow.
>> Oh, wow. So, they're not fans, eh?
>> They don't like this.
>> Oh. Huh.
>> That's pretty bad because normally
they'll cheer for literally anything.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Hey, look at all look at all those
likes.
>> Let me go ahead and add let me go ahead
and add one more.
[Laughter]
>> I love your videos, but please don't
make this type of AI videos. Let's go
ahead and give that a likes. You know
what I'm saying?
>> Comics, too.
>> Whoa, look at that.
>> Win shake of mine.
>> Look. And he hearted that one.
>> Wow. He actually harded that one. He
didn't he didn't read like this one. He
seen all these but he liked this one.
Huh? He like that one. Let's see another
one. Let's see. I thought it was haram
to replicate Allah's creation like this
voice and image since that's clearly AI
of Shikman.
>> Everyone's going to start worshiping
that image, man. What they already do.
>> Are you Are you telling me that if you
remove the eyes that makes it okay? Is
that is that his thinking there? That's
really weird to me.
>> But there's nothing to back it up.
>> See, this is what shakes do, guys. They
always try to look for loopholes.
>> Loophole. Loophole loophole. But the
Muslims aren't buying it. They're
actually calling them out on it.
>> Incredible.
>> They g loophole.
>> Loophole.
>> So now,
>> you know that he took off his eyes.
Look, because the color is slightly
different.
>> Yeah. So he made it and then they had to
color. Yeah. Yeah. Doc is right. It had
eyes and then they actually eyes.
>> Yeah.
>> They cropped it out.
>> Yeah. Cuz he was like he was like, "No,
Muslims will instantly start
worshiping." And Muslims are like, "I
see images. I have to start worship."
Oh, wait. It's got no eyes. He They They
took out the eyes. Okay. Now I now I
know I now I know I can't worship it.
>> All right. So now let's actually just
hear this one more time so we can get
his claims accurate. And then I want you
guys to dissect this a bit. Okay. So
let's let's see.
>> If the Quran is preserved, why did Utman
burn copies of the Quran?
>> He burned copies with tribal dialects
and notes to protect the Quran.
>> Burning them sounds.
>> We'll pause it there.
>> Point number one. There's there's a lot
to say about that. So he says like
notes. I think he's trying to get at the
idea that these were personal copies and
stuff. You have footnotes, right?
>> He's the expert on footnotes, I have to
say.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> If there's a footnote, he knows it. He
knows
>> it's his one of his official names is
Shakeben footnotes. So,
>> there's no grounding for this. I mean,
ultimately the first compilation before
him was destroyed, right, by Abu Bakr
and Zibet. So, unless you want to think
that they killed lots of animals, got
lots of skins, produced this Quran, like
6,000 odd verses of it, so big thick
book or whatever, then decided to do
nothing with it cuz it was a personal
copy. That to me is insane. That's
that's absolutely insane to think that.
Why would you think that? So, I think
that like that kind of narrative is is
really dumb. Anyway, something that
destroys variance is not preserving
anything. No one in scholarship is going
to tell you if you go around destroying
variance, you're preserving something.
No, all you're doing is destroying the
variance. You're hiding it. You know,
you're literally taking stuff and hiding
it intentionally. And this is why
scholars today don't say we have the
Quran of Muhammad. They say we have the
Quran of Uman at best. if you can even
agree with that because you can't go
beyond man because you don't have
anything. He destroyed them all.
>> So So where did they get this idea that
oh you know what was burned were you
know copies that just had footnotes in
them and and other people's notes and
where did they get this from?
>> Yeah. Well that that's that's completely
made up. But also it's a it's a weird
situation where you could like suppose
we grant what you said. Supposedly the
Quran is so impossible to imitate and so
on that any Arab speaker if he saw notes
he's not going to confuse that with the
Quran. So that wouldn't have been
confusing at all. Why would you why
would you have a problem with notes? I
mean that would have just basically been
like tapsier and so on. So why would you
have a problem with that? Don't you
think Muslims could have that they would
have been able to tell the difference?
But uh even if you grant this this
common myth that he was just getting rid
of all the dialectical differences if as
they believe Allah revealed it in these
different dialects. Now that's there's
no real basis for claiming that that's
what the seven auf were. But supposing
we grant just for argument sake that
Allah revealed the Quran in all these
different dialects. Who in the name of
common sense gave gave the caiff um man
the authority to get rid of six out of
the seven different versions that Allah
revealed the Quran in? This is what
seriously amazes me is they'll come up
with all these explanations and you get
to the kirat and so on and then it's
like oh and this guy said it's seven
different kirat and oh no later on this
guy said 10 and they'll just take it for
granted. It's like who are these guys
prophets to you? Who gave these guys
authority to decide what Quran they want
preserved and what Quran they want they
want people to have access to. It's like
they need a bunch of inspired prophets
after Muhammad in order to even justify
all these things that they're doing. But
they don't have a problem with any. It's
like any random Muslim could come along
and say, "Up, you know what? I'm getting
rid of half the Qurans and I'm keeping
these and I decided that this and I'm
I'm saying it's this." And they'll just
Oh, yep. See that? That's fine. Like
what do they need to see before they
realize they've got a completely
man-made religion?
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Yeah. It's like when you ask them why
why burn the Quran, they'll say
something like to get rid of dialect
dialect. And then what about the Quran
today? They're all dialects. So did he
get rid of them or did they stay? Which
one is it?
>> A good point.
>> Well, he tried. So with this being said
now, so that's point number one that he
said. Let's see what else he says here.
So
>> suspicious.
>> He burned personal copies and dialectal
variations to prevent confusion. The
original Quran was not burned.
>> Do you So he did this to prevent
confusion. Burned tribal.
>> We're still confused.
>> We're still
>> And Muslims are still confused, too,
because you can get 50 different answers
about what this is. To DLC's point, if
his if his mission was to get rid of the
different dialects, the confusing
dialects, then why do they claim that
these different kat are still just
different dialects and not just
different Qurans, just different
dialects of the same Quran? Did he fail?
Did he succeed? What took place here?
>> Yeah, that's a good point. I want to
just illustrate as part of that little
clip we watched. It starts with you
saying that sounds suspicious. And I
just thought, well, hang on a sec. Wait,
wait. Is that symbolic of what you or
any of us have just said in response to
the first bit? No, we gave actual
points, detailed points to refute that.
And all he can make you say is that
looks suspicious. Which
>> that's it. No, no arguments. No points
actually. Just me just being skeptical.
I guess whatever this representative is.
>> Basically, I'm not sure.
>> I'm not sure. H I don't have a rebuttal.
>> What I find really interesting there is
he used the term original Quran, which
is funny because if you take that
literally, the original Quran when it
was first compiled was destroyed. So
that just that like from a literal
factual sense is wrong. Um man was the
second compilation of the Quran done 20
years after the original. And yeah
that's the one supposedly we have today
not the actual one produced by Abu Bakr.
So uh yeah that's not the case. And
again we don't we don't know what um man
changed. We don't know what he took out
what he added. I mean there are many
Muslim companions who had a lot of
issues with Uman and this Quran that he
supposedly made. Why not think that
their issues with him and the Quran that
he made is an indicator that he took
liberties with the compilation of the
Quran?
>> But of course, because he destroyed
everything else, you don't have we don't
have like, you know, scholarship doesn't
have any way of figuring out what was
before it. So you literally as a Muslim,
you have faith in an intentional
destruction of the Quran that you
believe that was done faithfully. It was
a faithful destruction of the Quran
according to Muslims. We don't have that
in our religion and thank God we don't.
>> Imagine if we did. imagine if Paul had a
closed transmission of of the New
Testament and uh they they would hop on
it if we had something in our history
saying, "See, Paul picked Timothy and
Titus and
>> he destroyed everything else."
>> Yeah. Destroyed everything else. Even uh
even got into a fight with Peter over
it. Beat beat Peter to a black.
>> Oh, and then said, "Here you guys go."
>> Following up with with what Chris just
pointed out, let me give two quotations
here. So this is from Iban Sad volume 2
page 444. Abdullah Ibn Masoud in
response to this official Quran by Zade
Iban Tabit. He said the people have been
guilty of deceit in the reading of the
Quran. I like it better to read
according to the recitation of him
Muhammad whom I love more than that of
Zadb. So this is Abdullahbnb Masoud
saying I like the Quran as it was
recited by Muhammad not the one like not
this guy's version. And then in jam at
eternity. So even Muslims who don't have
Iban Sad on their shelves, Jamity 3104,
Abdullah Ibn Masoud says this. Oh you
Muslim people, avoid copying the musaf
and recitation of this man. By Allah,
when I accepted Islam, he was but in the
loins of a disbelieving man, meaning
Zade ib and it was regarding this that
Abdullah ibn Masoud said, "Oh people of
Al Iraq, keep the Musahif that are with
you and conceal them." So he's saying,
"Hide your Qurans from this guy because
they want to burn them all." Now, now,
now just think about that. Whatever you
want to say these differences were, if
you want to say they're just dialects,
one, who gives this guy authority to
destroy six of the seven different ways
that Allah revealed them. Two, why did
Muhammad's top guy? Muhammad said, if
you want to learn the Quran from anyone,
learn it from Abdullahb Masoud and
Abdullah Masoud is the guy is the very
guy who's saying, "Don't go with this
guy's Quran. I like Muhammad's
recitation better than this guy's
recitation." What's going on? Was the
one they preserved not in Muhammad's
dialect? Because Abdullah Ibn Massud,
the very guy Muhammad said, if you want
to learn the Quran from anyone, learn it
from him, is freaking out saying, "Don't
go with that guy's recitation." I like
Muhammad's recitation better. So
>> just to add, David, real quick,
Abdullahb Masoud, as you pointed out,
David, he was one of the master reciters
of the Quran. That in hadith is called
that in authentic hadith is called that.
He was not invited to join Uman when he
was compiling his Quran. He was excluded
intentionally.
>> Wow.
>> So you got to think, hang on a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You've got the best guy who knows the
Quran like better than anyone else. He
is one of the best reciters, memorizers
of the Quran. You then have this guy
who's a califf now going, "hm, I don't
like Abdullahb Masjud. He's got this
different Quran. He's got his own
codeex, you know, all the way up north.
Kind of don't want him around, you know,
cuz it might make things a bit awkward
when we realize we have two different
Qurans. Yeah. I'm just not going to
invite him." And then I'm going to hope
like tell people to destroy his codeex
because uh that way no one finds the
evidence.
>> Yeah. And I just wanted to point out uh
you're talking about Abdullah Ibn Mass
Masoud not being invited here. This is
the one guy Muhammad invited out in the
desert to watch the uh the Zoot party,
right? This the one guy that's how
that's how tight. These guys are like
this. He's the only one. He's his
closest companion. Hey, I don't want
anyone watching what's going on with the
Zoot except this guy who also happens to
be my best reciter of the Quran.
>> Maybe he's worried he'd bring it up.
Like maybe he's worried he'd be like,
"Oh, you're missing the chhatra of
alut."
>> Yeah. What happened to the what happened
to surah alz? Hey, we need to write if
shikman wants to go the AI route. We'll
get AI to write surah al about the story
of uh of Muhammad and al complain. He
can't complain cuz cuz uh because it's
just AI and he's uh he's he's fine with
that.
>> Make sure you blink out their eyes, man.
Just make sure we blink out.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The zoot with no eyes.
And Muhammad with no eyes. See See, now
we know how to do Muhammad cartoons.
We'll just do Muhammad cartoons but no
eyes and then they won't they won't be
offended.
>> That sounds like permission. We've been
given permission by Shikman here. We got
a shake's opinion. This is Islamically
acceptable to represent the just as long
as they have no eyes.
>> Yeah. So this is guys, this is actually
like a different kind of Islamic
dilemma. It's like did Muhammad know the
Quran? Did he know who knew the Quran
best and who to trust best? If you say
yes, okay, that's Abdullah Ibn Massud.
That's what Muhammad said. And
Abdullahbn Massud said, "Guys, don't go
with don't go with Zade's Quran. Go with
the Quran. Go with the Quran as Muhammad
recited it, not this guy's Quran." So if
Muhammad knew who was the best reciter,
then the Quran you have today is wrong.
And if Muhammad didn't know who the who
the had the correct recitation, why you
believing in him? You believe in someone
else who's a higher authority than
Muhammad himself about the Quran and
that's Zimbab. So he must be the real
prophet here.
>> So these are the real type of rebuttals
that would have been brought out in a
conversation with Uman regarding the
different Qurans they have whatever
fabrication AI this was. Let's see what
he brings up and puts in your mouth like
in the in the thing. I bet it's nothing
like that.
>> I convert to Islam. Alhamdulillah.
>> The next scene is just Avery but like in
proper Islamic gear.
>> Right.
You've convinced me. You see?
>> No. But ladies and gentlemen, if you
guys do want to see an actual
conversation that I had with Uman
regarding the different Qurans, you can
check out this video. It's going to be
in the description. when he was in Baloa
Park, he came with Sneo and we discussed
if whether variants make a book corrupt
or not. And so he said yes for the
Bible. So then I had a field day with it
when it came to the Quran. So have fun
and enjoy watching that video. In the
meantime, make sure you guys hit the
like button, subscribe, and put it in
the comments section. Let's get some
engagement. Did you guys like the
debate, the AI debate? Tell me what
y'all think. Peace out. See y'all later.
I'm ready to convert.
[Music]
Oh my god. Logic.